i know you did honey
mommy's here
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars rick and
morty season 5 episode 3
a rick convenient mort just broke our
hearts by pointing out how
impossible it is to be truly
environmentally conscious
it ain't easy being green if it means
murdering coal miners
seriously what the
oh my god this is rick splained it's our
rick and morty after show where we love
to overthink rick and morty into
weird socio-political conclusions that i
now have to be a bit more careful how i
word after a few folk shows
couldn't take a joke and my last loki
breakdown
anyway my easter egg breakdown of this
rick and morty episode all the details
he missed is coming tomorrow but here
i'm with rick and morty superman and
planet here with the most
heart tommy hello eric
wow what a god what a weird episode
like very weird episode yes talk about
like a record scratch from what we had
seen the previous two weeks yeah
rick and morty does this sometimes it
embraces like the bleakest sides of the
existence you know it reminds you it's
not just gonna be joke joke
joke it's gonna make you feel and this
is an episode that did that but i'll say
as bleak as the episode seems
both about relationships and about the
environment i promise there is hope
for both of those things when you think
about specifically the question of what
morty did with planet tina's rings after
he got them all
oh and viewers by the way you may see a
shadow on the
blue um dungeon wall here darla my dog
is down here at my feet right now she's
lonely uh and needs attention because
last night was fourth of july and some
of those fireworks scared her a little
bit so she just you know needs to be a
little bit closer
to papa right now so she you may see her
creepy shadow moving around in the
background
um but she's a little camera shy even
right now she won't even jump up and say
hello we'll see if that happens
tommy let's break down what happened
this episode all right
uh i'll try to break down without
breaking down myself
uh morty falls in love with planet a
female captain planet parody voiced by
allison bree
but has to deal with her controlling
handlers to now grown-up
planeteers which is so brilliant such a
funny idea of having the kids from the
cartoon
be like dysfunctional adults yeah
for ortina tears in this case by the way
morty fights back against the one voiced
by steve buscemi
bites off his finger steals his ring
and then burns him alive as you do once
you have the power of fire
uh morty goes on a killing spree killing
all the rest of the teena tears
uh in various violent fashions to get
control
of all of the rings a very thanos moment
for morty yeah it's just
one by one he is an effort yikes he'll
do it himself
but blantina's environmentalism becomes
too extreme for even morty
when she kills hundreds of coal miners i
think he says you killed 300 people at
one point yeah
yeah it's like the uh don cheadle
captain planet funny or die
series that was amazing oh it's just so
dark but like
it you don't have to murder people but
you do have to we do have to take
extreme measures
yeah that's what's so funny about
watching this right the point of
the episode i think is like yeah maybe
you don't have to
drop coal miners to their death but like
it is not going to be an easy
fix it's not going to be just a like
throw your uh
as rick uh putting the aluminum can
in the recycling bin
now so in the b story rick takes summer
on a party to
three planets that are facing
apocalypses uh in increasingly gross
orgies but he then he gets too close to
one alien which is voiced by jennifer
coolidge one of my all-time favorites
daphne breaking his own rule of not
falling in love and uh keeping things
casual during these apocalypse orgies
summer wrecks it by saving the final
planet from destruction
rick forgives her saying it's something
he would do which is a very funny moment
where he
yeah kind of has is introspective and is
like well he's completely screwed me but
i would
absolutely have done this to someone
else
think to teach a lesson because you know
rick loves lessons that have uh
grandiose uh
on the gradient scale marty and planet
heartbreakingly break up
morty ends the episode crying in beth's
arms which is like yeah
something that we rarely see that type
of emotion between
morty and beth in in this year yeah it's
one of the believers we've seen
on the series especially considering the
implications about how hard it is to
embrace
environmentalism so uh
what is this episode saying about how
doomed we are
a lot i think it it's a lot um basically
we're even more doomed than you think
but
not all hope is lost and that's kind of
the general theme of rick and morty
like sure the more you think about
things the more depressed you will get
oh but that doesn't mean you should give
up all hope
yeah there's there's always a glimmer at
the end of the tunnel that
you can just cling to that that's all
you need but if you want to help
us make more great content lot at new
rockstars liker explained one of the
best ways you can support us is to check
out our merch at new rockstarsmerch.com
rick and morty aren't the only people
who freaking love merch we love merch
here too
and we have a line of exclusive loki
inspired merch based on the hit show on
disney plus designs that you won't find
anywhere else
in any other timeline support this
channel and go get yourself some
great swag by going to
newrockstarsmerch.com
but yeah this question again uh by
breaking up morty and planeteena is rick
and morty saying that our planet is
doomed as well
is it the end times um tommy i wanted to
talk to you about this because as i was
watching this at least the first time i
watched it the b
story felt a bit disconnected didn't it
like
yeah yeah totally it just seemed like a
true b story though yeah
legitimate completely detached plot but
they do this cool thing at the end
where you realize both story arcs are
actually about
the end of the world you know planeteena
is trying to save earth from climate
change
rick and summer are hedonistically
embracing the ends of three other worlds
until summer
saves a world but really just a
blocker grandpa
yes and when you're watching playing at
tina and morty's arc
it's interesting because neither of them
are wrong you know planeteen is
extremism it's extreme but it is
grounded in truth
right as we said coal miners do not need
to be murdered
arguably that wouldn't even change
anything we are not pro
coal miners not at all um
and like they even have an argument of
like look we need our jobs
you know this is just our way of life
you're not gonna change that for us um
but the um macro scale reality of this
is
humanity's addiction to fossil fuels is
killing the planet uh
and it's not even a debate anymore it's
just happening uh
and like you know i am someone who
obsessively researches this
uh because i have had uh my own life and
family members lives i've
lost a home due to a drought a fire
you know my brother has lost his
incredibly powerful super storm
in florida uh so i'm just kind of
curious to see where we're going and
what we can do
uh as i'm sure because rob schrab who's
dan harmon's longtime collaborator wrote
this episode
um i'm sure they've looked into this i
don't want to depress you guys too much
but it may be too late to prevent the
worst parts of climate change
that's just the horrific truth of this
according to nasa
at this point we are already living in a
global climate crisis and it's something
that we are seeing with increasingly
powerful storms and droughts extreme
heat here in the western u.s
uh and that even if we stopped emitting
all greenhouse gases
at this very second global warming
according to nasa would continue
for at least several more decades if not
centuries and nasa these are nasa's
words
and now they say responding to climate
change will be
uh requiring two tier approach
mitigation
which is you know trying to do our best
to reduce carbon emissions wherever we
can
but also adaptation which just means we
just have to learn to live with the
climate change that's already happening
you know that's you're gonna see it just
moving away from coastal areas and food
we're gonna see food shortages
unbreathable air from perennial
wildfires the gulf of mexico is always
gonna be on fire from
and like it's scary uh you're gonna see
shortages of drinking water that could
lead to water being priced like oil
becoming a commodity and being fought
over like oil is i'm gonna see water
wars
uh water i think it's not even
crazy anymore to suggest this and it's
so
depressing and it's so depressing that
those of us on the left and i do
consider myself on the left surprise
surprise
yeah the left doesn't like to talk this
way because it's so hopeless they're not
ever gonna say this
uh because they're worried it would risk
a response of well then screw it let's
not try to do anything
right but truly mitigation is a huge
thing and it would
it will make a huge difference to how
bad our kid lives our kids lives could
be
um we could make a huge difference still
uh but we just have to accept the
reality that adaptation will also be
something we all have to do
and i think this depressing backdrop is
why they title this
uh a rick or a rick rick convenient mort
you know it's
it's based on an inconvenient truth it's
al gore's global warming documentary
from 2006.
um so we see two different approaches to
this you see rick's approach which is to
embrace the end of the world just
let it happen live in the moment party
and it's interesting all three of these
planets are
all just parting they're the characters
in the disaster movies that are just
like getting drunk and just like cursing
the coming asteroid
uh they don't care um and i love this
moment that you point out tommy where uh
rick
litters his beer can and he argues
correctly that the earth is eight
percent aluminum uh he's like we need to
save every drop of elimination
you know he's right it's like aluminum
is not something that we're in shortage
of
right uh but uh he is kind of echoing
you're seeing this more people
there is this weird backlash against the
benefits
of recycling right right it's good to
recycle
but it's not the end-all be-all you're
not gonna it's you're not gonna change
everything just if you recycle
right um morty by contrast uh genuinely
loves planetina's environmentalism the
fact that she is a planet saver
and fights for the environment is
something that draws him to her
right but then he he ends up having to
do horrible things
including murder in order to liberate
her
which in his eyes is justified at that
moment because they were going to sell
her out to this like
this arms dealer or whatever you know um
but then when he sees her doing even
worse things
uh even when you could argue that harm
is comparatively small relative to
the the broader harm to the planet morty
cannot associate with that his
his morality just says it's a step too
far i can't i can't be part of this
um but i think it's good to see that
both story lines end with the younger
generation morty and summer
saving the planets in their respective
ways so summer destroys an asteroid
that's headed to fergus 9.
she has her reasons for doing it but she
does save that planet
uh and morty despite breaking up with
planeteena
does not if you notice continue to wear
the rings that control her
once he liberates her earlier in the
episode so presumably he must have given
those rings to her
right and i think that means he gave her
the means to continue to save the planet
even if it means horribly more coal
minor deaths
or work on old platforms or whatever but
he just can't bring himself to directly
associate with that he can't have the
blood on his head
the blood's always gonna be on his hands
though uh it's kind of like his
relationship with rick he's powerless to
stop the pain
he just you know has to live with that
pain right that's kind of what
morty is like horrible things are
happening
you are a witness even an enabler to
genocide
but you have to continue to live with
that because the universe is so chaotic
because pain and suffering is happening
all over the universe if you're aware of
it you now just have to carry that with
you everywhere you go
yeah but i think to me i
can't help but look at this as a sign of
hope that our younger generation will do
what needs to be done
including pissing off their grandparents
which is gonna have to happen
like our grandkids are gonna hate us and
they're gonna do stuff that makes our
lives shitty and we're gonna have to
live with that
right uh and then it also includes
they're gonna have to make heartbreaking
personal sacrifices too
because ultimately the children are our
future they're going to be smarter than
we are
life will find a way and that's just the
world we're going to live with
right um so that's the way i interpreted
this episode i'm sorry if that's that's
too depressing if i got too
environmental but like this is a show
that encourages us to think more and
more about that i mean i think about
science the tone of the entire show it
would be disingenuous to not
take it that way and be like oh this is
just a fun little romp about love gone
wrong
and you know and excessive partying it's
like no
this was one of those episodes much like
community which is no surprise because
these are all community
basically creatives uh that are like oh
this is
funny but it's also really sad and
really distressing
so yeah yeah yeah and i think that's
like
i mean you can interpret rick and morty
however you want if you just want it for
a vehicle for laughter and for
subversive jokes
great this was not the episode for you
though right and i think
all art uh even if it's just like you
know escapist goofballism
and rick and morty is yes those jokes
only hit so hard because it's a show
that's willing to go to dark places
right and it went to a very dark place
and it's not just about relationships
it's about our relationship to our
planet
right and i love that they open with
like captain planet because as a kid
that's what like i grew up with and it
is cheesy and hokey and you feel like a
nerd for even talking about it too much
but it's our home and it's where we live
and whether we're watching rick and
morty or if we're watching loki and
watching category 8 super storms wipe
out an oil refinery town or if we're
watching
uh you know christopher nolan's
interstellar and it deals with this
mysterious blight that is caused by
climate change on earth and that's why
we leave
i mean folks the billionaires are
leaving earth for a reason
right basis is going to space because he
knows this
they all know this they know it's
it's irredeemable you know but
i can't but i can order a book
today and it will be delivered by 11 a.m
tomorrow
so much we'll bring it to you and it's
great
and we get to like laugh our way down uh
like a quarter string quartz head on the
deck
yeah to the asteroid and it's
uh an apocalypse has never been so fun
can we at least admit that
well we've got great content as long as
we can we got great
content and great company right yes
yes and great sponsors and great
sponsors like hey
perfect segue this episode was
sponsored by you were perfect
perfect set up there this episode was
sponsored by better help
which you might need now more than ever
because if there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
we've all been there at some point some
of us are there right now well
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist and you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help it's
just professional counseling done
securely online
and there's a broad range of expertise
available for clients worldwide
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room or look for
parking
better help makes it easy and free to
change counselors if you need to it's
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling
and pr and financial aid is available
better help once you start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com ricksplained that's
betterhelp and join the over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
special offer for rick's playing
audience get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
ricksplained and if you're in uh the b
story of this episode
we have another sponsor who can help you
out because our friends at bluechew
have a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
so bluechu is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discrete package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength and if you hate swallowing
pills good news blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code ricksplain to check out
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code rick's
plan to receive your first month free uh
visit bluechu.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this show
all right so tommy yes uh a question i
had at the beginning of this episode
do you think morty is for all intents
and purposes and
adult at this point do you think maybe
he has always been or if not
when did this transition from child to
adult occur because he's been murdering
people
he's had his first relationship yeah i
yeah it's implied that he lost his
virginity in this episode right like
that was what the whole
sequence was i think but right i
i don't know i'm like kind of torn i
think i feel like
he for like the definition of what
like being an adult means having to make
like difficult decisions to like take
care of yourself and being independent
he has been that since very early on in
the series
but i think that the last scene of this
episode kind of showed that he is
not he is a kid trying to behave like an
adult
you know him crying in his mother's arms
to me is very much
the the show letting us know that like
he is still a kid
like he is still you know an emotional
you know uh deeply affected
uh youth ma i mean teenager that's just
experiencing this world in all these
different ways so i i
i think my in my opinion he's a kid
that behaves like an adult yeah um the
um
uh the show does do these little things
anytime
morty uh starts to do adult behavior
and specify that the thing he's having
sex with
is not a human uh it's either an
alien in this case they said he's like
she's like uh
several different elements and amount of
elements you know
as a sentient being so age doesn't
really apply
um so that's kind of their their uh way
out of that
but like i think what they're saying in
morty's case he's just experienced so
much
um as long as they don't cross specific
lines
they like can still explore the depths
of the way kids who have faced trauma
uh like see the world right and
but i think it was great to have that
moment where he's in his mother's arms
at the end
because like i'm telling you you've
experienced two times
breakups are devastating no matter which
side of them you're on
it's hard you know yeah and when you
have to break up with someone
when you know it's the right move to do
right it's
a different kind of pain right because
you feel like you've hurt someone else
and you have to now live with that guilt
but you also feel loneliness and
isolation yeah um
and you know so it was just fascinating
to show that moment both for beth and
for
morty yeah because yeah as you said
rarely we see that kind of emotion or
uh rarely do we get to see beth be a
good mom
right right yeah it was it was really
a a strange way to end
the episode you know other than the
post-credits scene which was just
ridiculous but like
yeah sure that one that would have
bridge too far for me i hate to say like
my
i'm i can do a lot with rick and morty
and laugh but like
i was like i don't know if they're even
really funny
there's an alien dad and son at
the end of the world i'm like
okay i guess like i get to me that was
more like
what's the most shocking thing we can
have like what's the most shocking
line of dialogue we can have as this
animated alien pops up in the crowd
because it could have been anything it
wasn't like that was specific
and then the decision to have that
post-credit scene but
anyway yeah i think the the initial joke
of just like saying something shocking
and i was like okay you have to heighten
it
i just do love the awkwardness there is
like a true
comedy in the awkwardness family going
to work the next day at a bakery
and like mom's not talking to us oh
because we had sex
but it there i do agree and in that b
storyline it was almost just like
too much chaos upon chaos you know and
and sometimes rick and morty does that
where it's just
we want to do crazy alien designs and
they're doing disgusting horrible things
right but it just didn't have the auto
erotic assimilation
um refined quality to it
where like just they have crazy race
wars because their nipples are different
sizes
it just felt like for all these planets
just to go straight to orgy
yeah and then like there was no twist on
it it was just like more extreme
i kept waiting for a twist there yes but
i while we're on the story line i just
thought
anytime rick and summer are partnered up
i find interesting
because we always think like is morty
becoming more like rick is morty
becoming
uh more you know violent and cynical
uh and just nihilistic whereas summer
has a more
like scalpel approach she's more
controlled in
her normalism the way rick is right so i
wonder like this also happened
in the uh premiere right where he sent
summer on the rick lantis
oh right yeah yeah do you think we're
gonna start seeing
is is summer becoming rick's go-to now
as
morty's just following his own journey
no i think so this
to me reminds me of
when i was in high school i had a group
of friends and one of our friends who
was like the de facto leader when he was
mad at one of us
he would really like
emphasize how much he was hanging out
with another person to try and make us
feel bad like he would be like
oh we're doing this we're going to this
party sorry just the two of us we're
rolling out to do this we're going like
we're going to go
to this bar or whatever i guess maybe
once we got to college
i think rick is just emphasizing summer
to like try and pull
morty back in i think it's his life okay
yeah that's his like desperation of like
i'm not gonna beg morty to do these
adventures with me but i am going to
hit him in the one spot that will make
him jealous which is
preferring his sister over him yeah he
literally put morty's like acid
rain burn shirt on her in that moment
yeah
they coordinated the new he's like yeah
you are the new chosen one now
right right uh it is just an interesting
uh
uh like morty is more chaotic you know
he's more like chaotic
neutral i don't know yeah he kind of
hovers from all different
yeah i would just call him chaotic good
i think he chaotic yeah
it's probably right because like he
loses control and anytime he gets super
violent he doesn't want to do that he
has to be like forced into violence as
his first self-defense and then he just
goes too far
whereas summer's willing to go there
right away right the way rickett
get preventative so we have a couple
more questions one more response we want
to thank is magic spoon
so most folks would like to eat better
but healthy breakfast doesn't always
have to be boring
magic spoon has the amazing flavors you
love but without all the bad stuff
there's zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four net grams
of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving and it's
keto friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free low-carb and gmo free
get yourself a variety pack of the four
flavors of cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter
my personal preference is for fruity but
i have heard a tell of folks mixing
cocoa and peanut butter together for a
diy
peanut butter cup flavor so go to
magicspoon.com ricksplain and grab a
variety pack and try today and be sure
to use our promo code rixplain at
checkout
to save five dollars off your order and
magic spoon is so confident their
product is backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked to remember your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code
ricksplain to save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
all right so tommy back to the episode
um the way this episode ends do you
think morty is going to be
like rick doomed to be alone like are
morty and rick mortician to watch when
they're
unhappy and heartbroken and isolated is
that just what we can expect
i don't no i don't think so i don't
think morty
i think the whole point of the show or
one of the main points of the show is
that morty is not like
you know like they keep trying to
convert he keeps becoming more like him
but then
kind of swerving away you know like
every time he gets close to just being
exactly like him so
i i don't think he's doomed to be alone
i think that the
that one of the hallmarks of the show
though is
giving him teasing giving him the chance
the the carrot of happiness and then
pulling it away at the last minute
yeah but i don't think ultimately i i
feel like he's probably
more i mean he has two different things
to look at he has his grandpa who is an
alcoholic maniac and then he has his dad
who is the most pathetic person on it so
like
his dad is i'm sorry can we talk about
that board game real quick yeah like
oh don't punch my gut i'm so full
the game is ridiculous oh my god
you know so i i wonder if some of
morty's like
being doomed to be alone isn't based on
his relationship with rick but more's
relationship with jerry
but i think ultimately that morning's
character is a little too sweet he's got
a little more of a sweet side than rick
does that
like it would imply that he will find
someone eventually
uh i think so it might not be the person
who's best for him but that's just kind
of the nature of
all storytelling when you're watching
sitcoms it's like it's it's rare to have
characters in
stable functioning relationships it's
just right it's more interesting to
watch conflict
also for i want to mention for our
conspiracy theory
uh theorist viewers rick was back
drinking this week so you can all relax
he's still drunk i saw that comment and
tweet so many times like why do you
think rick isn't drinking
and i'm like i don't know the first two
episodes maybe jeff loveness doesn't
have as
much of an affinity for drunk rick as
past writers i'm not sure well and he's
back yeah he drank a whole
um ship full of phonies yeah you called
boys 880
beers yeah
oh oh the thumbnail this video is gonna
be how many beers did rick drake
well i gotta count all the beers and
let's end with this question of planet
tina
like she's still alive do you think
we're gonna return because you have this
vindicators episode coming up
and jillian jacobs voice supernova in
the vindicators
right so do we think planeteena her
community co-star they could team up in
the video
i i i have very little doubt that we see
planet again
i think yeah i think that character is
definitely coming back
yeah i think no one's more interesting
than like a
uh a super-powered sperndex girlfriend
in the rick and morty universe right
who's now gone completely unhinged too
like in terms of like violence and like
no yeah i know she
like she could become like a uh a
thanos-like villain of something
the world is overpopulated it must be
done all things balance
you know right um i hope she comes back
i want her to be kind of like uh
a bird person flash phoenix person yeah
uh
an um periphery character who says
always in the world
well that is it for this episode of rick
explained uh sorry to bum you out but
that's the episode they gave us so
that's the conversation we're gonna have
about it
you know but don't worry there was
plenty to laugh at this episode
so many great hidden jokes that's all
coming in the breakdown
that's coming out tomorrow on the
channel and uh tommy and i will be back
next week to react to episode four
so be sure to follow tommy at tommy
bechtold follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
ricksplain wherever you get your
podcasts
thank you for watching and we'll close
with our favorite moment of the episode
what do you mean no don't i wouldn't be
a bird
[Music]
foreign